okay I want to thank everyone for coming
this reading of my book under the knife
how are wealthy Negroes surging will to
power in Jim Crow South the book it
windows the inner acquires message we
know it's not the right word hones in on
my great uncle who was a wealthy surgeon
here in the state of Georgia who built a
hospital in southwest Georgia and the
town of Bainbridge which is about 40
miles north of Tallahassee Florida the
capital of the state of Florida but the
book also encompasses a lot more than
that it encompasses the history of
african-americans in the field of
Medicine in the early part of the 20th
century the late part of the 19th
century early part of 20th century it
also encompasses a history of my family
or small history of my family and and
kind of like how I got into deciding to
write the book the reviews of the book
came out in February and in March and
just about all of them were very very
positive and glowing except for one
which was written by man named Jonathan
Yardley of the Washington Post
now Yardley not only wrote a review
excoriating me but he also wrote a
review with tremendous errors in the
review he misquote he attributed a quote
of one of my interviewees a man named
Paul cholesky in Chapter 11 he missed
attributed that quote to me he said that
one of my aunts wrote a biography of my
great-uncle an elderly aunt of mine when
she was actually 40 years old when she
wrote the book he did a number of scenes
a number of things in his review that
just were totally totally totally
erroneous and I wrote her letter to The
Washington Post about the review and the
Washington Post did not print the letter
I just wanted to say that because I
think a lot of people do not realize the
kinds of things that go on behind the
scenes within the book review community
and how unfair reviewers can be and how
for what I want for whatever reasons
they are not called on the carpet for
being unfair Yardley happens to be the
top book reviewer at the Washington Post
he's kind of to the Washington Post what
Michiko Kakutani is
two New York Times so I think that the
Washington Post decided not to print my
rebuttal of his very erroneous and
grossly unfair review because they
thought it would be embarrassing for
their readers to know that their top
reviewer obviously did not read the
entire book if you read the entire book
somehow he was struck with a bad case of
an inability to comprehend what he was
reading so I just wanted to say that at
the outset because he excoriated me for
taking a personal approach upon a book
about a man that I knew I mean this is
my grandma maternal grandmother's oldest
brother who became a very wealthy and
powerful man during the era of
segregation and the reason why I decided
to write the book was because I had
experienced so many different things by
the time I reached the age of 39 when I
started the project I'm 42 now that I
wanted to know well you know with all
the things that I'm going through with
my Ivy League education paid for by a
father who was also a physician what on
earth were the things that were that my
great-uncle went through who became a
millionaire here in the state of Georgia
during the Jim Crow era so in the book I
let the reader know that this is exactly
the approach that I'm taking I go I tell
the reader that I came down to Georgia
in 96 to cover because at the time I was
at editorial page writing for The Wall
Street Journal so I came down to cover
the funeral of Alice Hawthorne the woman
who was killed in the Olympic bombing he
got Olympics bombing here in Atlanta and
then from there we actually lived in
Albany I went to Bainbridge Bay which is
about 60 miles from Albany and I wanted
to go to Bainbridge because I had just
been to a funeral it was depressing and
I and I knew I was 60 miles for my
great-uncle had built his hospital and I
wasn't getting along very well the
people I was working with the Wall
Street Journal they're very conservative
I wasn't a conservative and I told him
from the very beginning of my employment
I I am NOT a conservative so we weren't
getting along so I was I was thinking
well you know with all the things I'm
facing and dealing with with these
people the journal you know little it's
just petty little mind game type things
that you did people deal with they're
working period but I think African
Americans deal with even more I was
wondering well you know what on earth
did Joseph Howard Griffin my maternal
grandmother's oldest brother what did he
have to deal with and so that's how he
started the book off and I guess I
discovered more and more things things
that I've in the back of my mind
new had have been true about his life I
tell the reader this as I go along so
that's the kind of the genesis and the
reason why I took a very personal
approach to writing this book so in in
familiarizing you but with passages of
the book and what the book is all about
I want to begin with how I set the stage
for everyone in understanding how an
african-american man an ambitious
intelligent talented african-american
man could have lived down here in a time
period it was absolutely horrendous for
African Americans a time period where
when he was growing up African Americans
were being lynched every week somewhere
in the south
here the state of georgia led the nation
in lynchings in the dense fear of the
period when he when he grew up how he
could have decided he was going to
become a physician because it was very
very difficult for African Americans to
become physicians back in those days he
graduated from medical school in 1915
and nink and then instead of heading
north he's headed north for a little
while to observe physicians at Cook
County Hospital in Chicago and the
hospital of the University of
Pennsylvania in Philadelphia but then he
came back to the South decided he wanted
to start his practice in Stewart County
Georgia which is about 35 miles south of
Columbus Georgia and then he found out
he couldn't stay in Stewart County
because it's the the Caucasians in
Stewart County did not run in an
african-american position there that's
how bad things were so he left and
started going to towns like he went to
Columbus Georgia he didn't like Columbus
he went to Albany he didn't like Albany
so finally he was invited by a Jewish
man in the town of Bainbridge to come to
Bainbridge Georgia and that's where he
started his practicing eventually he's
launched his first hospital which was a
30 not 30 but it was a 17 now 18 bed
hospital which he named after his his
in-laws
he called it Johnson Memorial Hospital
and then in 1950 he built his second
hospital 50 bit hospital which was the
largest Hospital for African Americans
in the state of Georgia
so the passages I want to read at the
beginning of this deal with the kind of
accommodation that African Americans
decided they had they had to make in
order to live here
the Rica's is most people probably know
the Reconstruction era lasted from
roughly after the Civil War until 1877
when the Republicans wanted to elect
their president Rutherford behaves and
the South said okay well if you want the
electoral votes to elect this man you
have to get out move out of the south
yet to stop occupying the south and
that's when reconstruction ended in 1877
all of the Caucasians were the the the
the political system here was was handed
back over to Caucasians
african-americans with distant franchise
you had all the horror of Jim Crow
etcetera coming down so what happened
was African Americans down who said well
you know how on earth are we gonna
survive in this atmosphere and Booker T
Washington was the leader who was chosen
who decided that he had the solution so
in order for the African Americans to
survive here in the South in that time
period up until Jim Crow was eradicated
in like officially in 1964 but the
movement started in 55:56 they had to
kind of abide by the the philosophy of
Booker T Washington so the first
actually I want to read deals with how
Washington came up with folk this
philosophy actually the first speech he
made which was here in Atlanta in 1895
at the cotton states exposition Atlanta
had a exposition in 18 1895 very much
like the act the exposition that they
had well that exhibition was the
Olympics which was you know the
competition they had here in 96 they
brought people from all over the country
and and in some parts of the world here
to Atlanta to you know to just find out
what the South was doing to resurrect
itself from from this horror of the
civil war in the aftermath of the Civil
War and was called the cognitive states
exposition and at this exposition Booker
T Washington made the speech that
basically said in all things purely
social we can be as separate as the
fingers yet one as in the hand and all
things essential to mutual progress but
before he made this speech there was a
man named dr. JW Bowen who made a speech
that we but it when Washington was all
about that rebutted the notion that we
should accept segregation that we should
accept an education that basically
taught you how to be a good bricklayer
or carpenter or something like that but
not an education to taught you to be a
lawyer or a physician or PhD so the
first passage I wanna read deals with
that
and I want to deal with how what what
dr. JW born said before Washington made
his speech would cuz dr. Boren spoke on
the same day Washington spoke but maybe
a few hours before Washington spoke so
this passage deals with what he said
versus what Washington said what dr. jwe
Bowen a theologian from Gannon
Theological Seminary in Atlanta said has
been forgotten by most historians
because of the manner in which
Washington's philosophy ultimately
prevailed but the pressure on Washington
to make a speech that would convince
virtually all Negroes that his was the
best course to follow because became all
the greater duty Bowens eloquent
addressed the negroes place will be what
he makes for himself one class contends
that he must earn it by staying in the
three RS and they make special efforts
in ridiculing the higher education of
the Negroes even for leaders in church
and state yes he must learn the three RS
he must master the King's English and
then you must clean his pinions of
thought for flight with Copernicus
kempler and Herschel i'ma sharpen his
logic for a walk with Plato Immanuel
Kant and Herbert Spencer he must clarify
his vision for investigations with
Virgil Huxley and gray he must be able
to deal in Hampshire's questions of law
as do Gladstone judge story and judge
Speer he must fortify himself to divine
rightly the word as do cannon for our
foster bishop hey good dr. John Hall dr.
H L Whelan in short the education of the
Negro must be on par with the education
of the white man it must begin in
kindergarten is that of the white child
and n in the university is that of the
white man now after he made this speech
which was I believe was in the Negro
Couvillion at the exposition Washington
became part of this procession the
opening ceremonies to the exposition and
made the speech with which history
remembers him for so I want to read the
passage that deals with what Washington
was dealing with as he began making the
speech at the opening ceremonies for the
exposition as Washington began to speak
Caucasians in the audience found
themselves interested in what he had to
say despite themselves cognizant of the
fact that the first thing a person
perceived unworthy always does his thank
his benefactors for being beneficent
Washington showered them with excessive
thanks for allowing him to speak a trait
that survived from slavery
trait that became woven into the
collective Negro psyche when in the
presence of Caucasians a trait our
forefathers would teach their children
their children would teach us and so on
next he urged Negroes to remain in the
South something our forefathers were
beginning not to do and hope of living
somewhere where they could enjoy their
full rights as US citizens though
Caucasian southerners at that time
certainly didn't want them to leave
because they needed their cheap manual
labor in an era before technology
rendered their presence unnecessary next
as though he was speaking to a group of
masters about their good and faithful
dogs he reminded the Caucasians of
Negroes patience and loyalty they liked
that they listened even more intently he
tried to recover some price speaking of
Negroes desires for self-improvement and
opportunities and in the southern
economy that was all we asked for he
said and if given that the Caucasians
would be assured of the continued
presence of the most patient faithful
law-abiding and unresentful people the
world had ever seen so now he wait for
the knockout punch he assured them that
just as they desired and all things
purely social we can be as separate as
the fingers yet one at the hand and all
things essential to mutual progress okay
now after you reading this passage to it
I want to read a passage that deals with
the other side of my family my Pearson's
side because as I said in the narrative
of the book I talk about how I went to
cover the funeral of al's Hawthorne for
the editorial page of The Wall Street
Journal's my idea not their idea and
then after going to cover her funeral I
went to visit my aunt in Tallahassee
Florida who teaches at Florida A&M and
then I went to South East Georgia
actually South Central Georgia but more
to the eastern side where my father's
side of the family is from and I went to
like where my grandfather Pierson had a
farmer for 475 acre farm in the wheeler
County Georgia and I was thinking about
what he dealt with and the fact that my
father never ever told me anything about
what it was like excuse me for one
second my father never told me anything
whatever about what it was like growing
up in Jim Crow and I was growing up in
Indiana because he he even though he
grew up here in Georgia he went to
medical school at Meharry Medical
College and then after leaving me Harry
got an internship in Lansing Michigan
and then decided to stay in the north
and we ended up settling in in the air
so when I was growing up I was very for
coaches they used to love to read about
current events and I would ask my father
boy what was it like growing up on there
under all that repression my father
would say those crackers never bothered
us they just they don't bother those
Pearson's they're crazy which wasn't the
truth I mean like you know we they my
family was more prosperous than other
african-americans in the area but they
had to make some compromises and one of
his sisters my aunt Mamie who lives in
Kansas City told me more about of the
truth of what he was actually dealing
with so this passage deals with some of
the things that she was telling me about
him this is about Nathan Pearson who was
born in 1882 and like I said had a farm
in in wheeler County Georgia despite all
his hard work independence and pride
touch just beneath the surface of who he
was we remained that ever-present
race-based fear after constructing a
home for his family he didn't paint it
no afro-americans in the community had
painted houses the reason that was
considered too uppity if it was painted
he told his family the crackers might
come and burn the place down with us in
it then there were the times when the Ku
cut the local Ku Klux Klan would parade
through the rural Negro community in
search of a Negro girl who kept having
children out of wedlock with the
intention of beating such ways out of
her rather than having the audacity to
try to prevent it grandpa like all the
other Negro men in the area decided it
was best to ignore it all largely
because she wasn't someone they wanted
to shine any light on anyway
highlighting a negative racial
stereotype even though it had have eaten
away at their sense of male pride that
they were unable to protect her instead
grandpa insisted on protecting what was
definitely his this is my aunt made me
speaking every time the clam paraded
down the road to get her he take his gun
and hide in the bushes on our property
line to ensure that they didn't do any
damage to our property we call that
Mamie for that day and time it was a
brave act but there were other times
when he seemed not so brave and
counseled his children as to why such
gestures really amounted to a certain
necessary cunning in order to survive
after leaving the farm his daughter
loved Esther the second oldest child do
huh to whom I am so close she is virtual
surrogate mother to me now graduated
from Talladega college in Alabama in
1938 she was valedictorian of her class
my grandparents was sent all nine of
their children to college which was
unusual in that day and age for
southerners period to do however grandpa
couldn't afford to send her to graduate
school to earn a master's degree in
French the way she'd want it so she had
to teach high school all afro-american
high school teachers in the public
school systems of Georgia at that time
had to be selected by Caucasians she got
grandpa to drive her to her first
interview prior to attending Talladega
aunt Levesque to attend as attended
Ballard High School in Macon Ballard was
a private school for Afro Americans that
had been established by New England
missionaries only a fortunate few Afro
Americans were able to attend a school
of that caliber at the school of the
Caucasian teachers from the north taught
the students the same day the same way
they would have taught them if they were
New Englanders that is the youth weren't
instructed to be deferential to
Caucasians the manner it was customary
back then to teach afro-american
children to be the same was true at
Talladega so when an investor sat for
her interview she answered the questions
put to her by the Caucasian woman with
yes or no this was a potentially fatal
mistake since Afro Americans were always
supposed to answer Caucasians with yes
ma'am or yes sir etc according to aunt
maybe Mamie who was also their grandpa
was sitting without Levesque too while
she was answering the questions upon
hearing that she wasn't attending ma'am
to his answers to her answers rather she
started fidgeting Olive Esther also
answered questions with I did or I did
not which is another trick that proud
Afro Americans used to avoid being
deferential in the way expected grandpa
continued to fidget after the interview
when we got back to the car pop let her
have it
he told her you cannot do that I have to
live here with these crackers but you
can go away he was terribly upset and I
want to continue on with another passage
that follows that it talks about my
father because my father who was the
shortest of the four boys in the family
were five girls and four boys was the
most rebellious of them all with regard
to being in the south which I think was
the major reason he decided he couldn't
come back to the south after finishing
his medical training so this in this
passage deals with my father's
rebelliousness and in a something that I
saw when my grandfather was on his
deathbed and he feared most of all for
my father pop was always scared for your
daddy and made me recall because he just
wouldn't buckle under to Caucasians the
way he was supposed to a hint that this
has been true even while he was growing
I was graphically demonstrated to me
when I was 13
my father and I traveled to Georgia
because my grandfather was on his
deathbed he would dial weeks later after
which we and the rest of our immediate
family would return for his funeral it
was the spring of 1971 seven years after
the end of Jim Crow though public
facilities were no longer segregated
other old habits were dying a slow death
and in the hospital where my 88 year old
grandfather lay half asleep
an elderly Caucasian woman stuck her
head in door of his room but seeing my
grandfather on his deathbed she said Oh
uncle I'm so sorry you're sick I'll be
praying for you uncle was the
traditional Appalachian Caucasians
attached to Negro men particularly older
Negro men during Jim Crow part of the
etiquette of quote/unquote respect for
them well Negro amendment were referred
to as auntie the rationale behind
creating the marketing names and faces
of Aunt Jemima and Uncle Ben and
apparently the tradition was still alive
at that time in east south central
Georgia not missing a beat my father
sitting in the chair next to the bed
looked up to the woman replied now if
he's your uncle that must make us first
cousins and I don't remember my father
introducing you as a member of our
family the woman was taken aback calmly
but firmly my father walked up to her
and continued things like that aren't
said anymore when you're talking to my
father referred to him as mr. Pearson
sheepishly the woman apologized and
closed his door but I got the sense that
normally local Afro Americans would have
still accepted what she had done so you
know that basically it just gives you an
idea of the kind of things that that my
father was doing as opposed to other
people in this area
now the other passage I want to read
before getting into my great-uncle and
Esther they a couple more passages
before getting to inter to him and what
he was doing in southwest Georgia kind
of also sets the stage for understanding
the the psyche of African Americans in
this era and it deals with something was
going on here in Atlanta I talk about a
fairly well-known writer at least well
known to historians it was a riot that
occurred here in Atlanta in 1906 and a
lot of young people don't know
today that back in those days when uh a
riot took place
it usually meant Caucasians were
attacking African Americans instead of
African Americans in in the ghetto you
know just just getting really angry and
and destroying and everything and you
know in the wake of some sort of racial
injustice
so what will usually happen was what
would be what then a rumor was started
the Caucasian women had been raped or
attacked and in some other manner or
whatever and then you know people would
come down and they would just decimate
the african-american community I guess
the most recent example of something in
that time period that has been in the
news is what happened in Tulsa Oklahoma
but it this type of thing happened in
Tulsa it happened here in Atlanta
it happened in East st. Louis Illinois
so the leaders in the african-american
community and the leaders in the
Caucasian community would get together
to try to decide well how can we make
peace and this passage right here deals
with the kind of peace that was made and
the kind of atmosphere the kind of
philosophy that african-americans who
were ambitious kind of instilled within
each other for how you survive in this
area of the country and also prosper so
this is this passage deals with what the
leaders in here in Atlanta
african-american leaders did to make
peace the leaders were thrust between a
rock and a hard place
in other words segregation forced a
certain level of cooperation between
educated Negroes and the masses yet
after such watershed events as the
Atlanta riot of 1906 duplicated
elsewhere with similar riots in many
cities and towns across the country the
educated could do nothing that
ultimately interfered with Caucasian
desires for a cheap pliable and
basically ignorant Negro labor force
however the elite would conclude the dis
root advancement this straddling of two
motives advancement as well as
complacency could eventually lead to
economic and social freedom I was in the
Atlanta riot garland pin told the Negro
physicians dentists and pharmacists
attending the National Medical
Association convention in Washington
four years later I got out of it too I
said to myself as I walked up and down
in my room that night pin what have you
done for this mob to come after you I
got the answer by race identity in spite
of myself I am linked with my brother
down on Decatur Street and Atlanta
Street known for tawdry activities and
dance halls and lesson comes to me that
I am no safer than he will let me be and
there with all our struggles upward we
have got to trust
touch the man in the gutter and lift him
up you may want to get away from it he
told the physicians dentists and
pharmacists for is always a tendency of
the intellectual man to want to get away
from it it would be a good thing if this
organization and the Negro business
League and other organizations would get
together and compile all the issues in
one
we collect information concerning the
progress of the Negro race and had that
progress printed for distribution
throughout this country so that we can
put our case and is proper and we can
put excuse me so we can put our case in
its proper place alright now the next
passages that I want to read gets into
my great uncle and deals with what he
started encountering in famous Georgian
Decatur County Georgia when he started
his practice one of the problems of
African physicians encountered in this
era was that African Americans didn't as
well as Caucasians didn't trust their
medical acumen so when he came to
Decatur County Georgia he'd be the
beginning he had problems getting people
to trust his abilities as a physician
and the way he got around that was that
just before coming to Decatur County
he had enlisted in the army and he'd
gone in as a lieutenant and I've been
sent to Fort Leonard Wood in Missouri
during the time which the United States
was getting involved in World War one
and this was when the great flu epidemic
the worldwide flu epidemic of 1918 had
just come to the United States and he
learns something about a treatment for
the epidemic so that when he left the
Army shortly afterwards and came to
bambridge he was only physician in
Decatur County in that particular corner
cuz the Kerr County is right at the
corner where Georgia Florida Alabama
meets so he was only position in the
area who knew of an effective treatment
for this flu epidemic because those
leading physician in Bainbridge was
killed when he died as a result of the
epidemic so after he started treating
people of all colors for this epidemic
he gained the confidence of African
Americans Caucasian people started going
back to their own physicians after the
epidemic and the African Americans in
the area started going to him anyway
another example of something they dealt
with there was common for African
American physicians in the rural South
to deal with was an African American
would go to Caucasian physician to see
you know what what they're diagnosed
with that physicians diagnosis was of
what what ailed them and if they didn't
like the Caucasian physicians diagnosis
they were good
african-american physician and CEO find
out what he said but the danger there
was with it was that if the African
American physician contradicted and his
diagnosis is what the Caucasian
physician said that there was a danger
that he might get run out of town
he might you know even be lynched so my
great-uncle faced a situation like this
in Bainbridge where he decided that that
the Caucasian physician who had missed
diagnosis woman he decided well you know
I'm gonna go ahead and I'm gonna save
this woman's life so this passage deals
with what he was doing with a Negro
female was bought was brought to doctor
a B Alfred a Caucasian physician in town
for a diagnosis of what ailed her he
performed exploratory exploratory
surgery and told her that she had cancer
and only a few months to live as often
happened after being dissatisfied with
what a Caucasian physician said the
woman was taken to Joe Griffin for a
second opinion upon examining her his
his diagnosis was that she suffered from
a uterine tumor with intestines adhere
to the tumor the situation was dangerous
rather than attempt to do something
about it dr. Alford has simply stoned
her back up and sent her on her way Joe
Griffin sought a second opinion from a
Negro colleague dr. TV makuu who
practiced 80 miles away in Eufaula
Alabama
makuu came to Bainbridge confirmed his
diagnosis and suggested he operates soon
because her condition was getting worse
and the KU agreed to assist in the
procedure but when the time came perform
it he said he was unable to return to
Bainbridge a Negro physician in
Thomasville and one in Tallahassee made
themselves scarce as well
Joe Griffin's nurse started to cry dr.
Alfred told you the girl's gonna die
he's just gonna ruin yourself she sobbed
his wife agreed doc doctor offers said
she is going to die and I wouldn't touch
her the situation has stirred up quite a
bit of attention and emotion all over
town if she died it would mean that Joe
Griffin had the audacity to consider his
expertise above that of a Caucasian
physician and then sacrifice his
patients life on the operating table
proving that he was arrogantly wrong it
was a possible outcome that perhaps
accounted for the unavailability of the
other Negro physicians for such a
transgression he could be driven from
town maybe even lynched he chose to go
ahead with the procedure it was a
success the girl lived after performing
it he was so exhausted that he got in
his car drove out into the country part
under a tree fell asleep
and didn't wake up until the next
morning from that point on whenever
doctor offered encountered him in town
he crossed the street and looked the
other way okay now the next thing I want
to do is I want to jump from there to
I'm gonna go a little bit of maybe like
about 20 years down the road 20 30 years
down the road when after you know he
gained the confidence of the
african-americans in the area and opened
up his first hospital in 1950 opened up
his second hospital and by that time he
had become very well known throughout
Southwest Georgia in Georgia period and
in the northern Florida and Alabama and
all that and so when he opened up his
second hospital which he built for a
quarter of a million dollars all of his
own money which was a lot of money back
then if he's built the same hospital in
the year 2000 it would have cost him
about 1.3 million dollars but anyway
when he opened it up Ralph McGill who
was editor of the Atlanta Constitution
decided to come down and speak at the
opening ceremony so I want to read the
passages it talks about what it just
gives you a sense of like the this team
that he was held in by a time you open
up a second Hospital and this this the
passage begins by describing what I was
thinking else as I was talking to a man
named Bertram Ehrlich who was telling me
a lot of things about my great-uncle so
I was sitting in his apartment and he
was telling me some things did you find
out in the book what you know what he
was telling me as you read but it just
begins talking about what I was thinking
as I was talking to mr. Steele as I sat
in his apartment
mr. Elks apartment and thought back to
the front page column in the Atlanta
journal-constitution published by the
south venerable Ralph McGill on Sunday
August 6th 1950
I couldn't resist feeling the same sense
of pride I had felt when I was 14 I
first read an old clipping of that
column McGill was editor of the
Constitution along with luminaries such
as newspaper owner hodding Carter of
Greenville Mississippi he'd become the
pride of liberal Caucasians in the south
the voice of moderation in that ocean of
racial apartheid serfdom ignorance
insecurity and caricature that it
resulted in his inhabitants becoming the
laughingstock of the rest of the country
deep in southwest rural Georgia not far
from Florida's capital city of
Tallahassee I found a meaningful
American story he wrote he went on to
describe that story as owning of Joseph
Griffin
and larger more modern hospital three
days earlier Magilla traveled to
Bainbridge to give the keynote address
at the dedication ceremony in the town
square
sitting with them on the days along with
Uncle Joe we're bein ridges mayor the
Caucasian Chaney Griffin the chairman of
the City Commission and the county
health commissioner in the audience that
hot sunny day were hundreds of people
from the Georgia Florida Alabama
tri-state area things had changed into
1930s there were far fewer lynchings Joe
Griffin's importance to the local
economy was secure respected Caucasians
in the region viewed the opening of his
new hospital as proof that segregation
could work a belief they were eager to
reinforce due to fear that due to their
fears that changes in their way of life
would soon be ordered by the US Supreme
Court the court was beginning to hear
cases challenging Jim Crow in the region
schools since the south had lived up to
the equal part in his separate
provisions for Negroes McGill too viewed
the opening as a way to prove critics in
the north wrong about the way of life
practiced in the region he hadn't yet
reached the point where he supported
integration at that time no Caucasian in
the south who expected to hold a
position of authority for very long
supporting integration support for
separate equality was the liberal
position and that was the point of
Miguel's column which marveled that my
great uncle managed to build a
well-equipped hospital using then
fabulous quarter of a million dollars of
his own money a facility where he would
invite Caucasian physicians to treat
their de negro patients as well
nationally syndicated columnist Elmer
wheeler also highlighted the opening in
his column entitled success secrets he
wrote recently a friend of mine brought
up the old-fashioned philosophical
teaser does man have free will or his
will so conditioned by heredity and
environment it's all decided for him
what he can and cannot do I did not
waste time I just told him the story of
Joseph H Griffin MD Bainbridge Georgia
dr. Griffin recently opened his corner
of million-dollar Hospital
Keibler he built it all himself no one
knows who put the idea in this Negro boy
his head that he could rise above
limitations of his environment maybe it
was because nobody told him about the
limitations of heredity and environment
and the condition of the human will it
was those words in the wealth of my
great uncle and the fact that he on that
day he opened the largest part of the
hospital for Negroes in the state and my
father's assurances that the races down
there you should say don't bother those
Pierson's they're crazy and the prestige
of the MDS
your Uncle Joe's uncle Davis and my
father's names that told me given líneas
like that I wasn't supposed to hang out
on street corners I wasn't supposed to
speak jive which by the late sixties
early seventies I've been trying my best
to do to blend in with the rest of the
boys in my neighborhood and the inner
city kids bused to our school as we
promoted black power in our own
misdirected manner okay now the next
passage I want to read deals with a
little bit goes back to a little bit of
the african-american medical history
that I as I've told you was in the book
um at the beginning of the book as I
said I talked a lot about African
medical history but in Chapter seven I
about what my great-uncle was all about
and how he started out in Bainbridge and
how he eventually became powerful in
Bainbridge but then I go back and talk
about a man who was a contemporary of
his a man named dr. Lewis T Wright who
grew up here in Atlanta and ultimately
left Atlanta went to medical school at
Harvard and settled in New York City and
became one of New York City's most
talented and esteemed surgeons so I want
to deal with a passage talking about
what Wright was dealing with when he
decided he wanted go to harvard medical
school rather than Howard I'm a Harry
which is vast majority of
african-american physicians were coming
out of so this deals this passage
actually deals with what he encountered
when he came to Harvard to try it in and
set up an interview and and be tested
for admission to Harvard Medical School
Wright was promptly referred to dr. otto
Folan an internationally famous
biochemist on the faculty the interview
grew heated in a voice dripping with
superiority and condescension Folan
asked mr. Wright
have you any sporting blood in your
veins yes right responded will you agree
if you with if I ask you a few questions
here today that I will never be bothered
with you again in life
yes right responded again to phone to
phone his astonishment right Pasteur
oral exam with flying colors
he received his MD from Harvard in 1915
[ __ ] laude ranking fourth in a graduating
class of 87 students this average for
the entire four years was a mere point
to seven percentage points behind the
class deal but because he received one
black ball from a Jewish student from
Memphis he wasn't elected alpha-omega
honorary medical society this despite
the fact that the student he also
conducted research that would serve as
the basis for his first published paper
on the effects of alcohol on the rate of
discharge from the stomach such academic
excellence also meant nothing when it
was time to apply for an internship
right was unable to obtain one at any of
the reputable hospitals in Boston so he
applied to Friedman's Hospital in
Washington and was successful
like Daniel Hill Williams Louis do you
right eventually evolved into the type
of Negro physician the John a Kenny
senior had once complained there weren't
enough of 1929 he became the first Negro
physician appointed a police surgeon for
the city of New York scoring higher than
all but one other person on a medical
exam in 1936 he devised a splint for
cervical fractures twelve years later he
developed a plate for certain types of
fractures of the femur in 1934 he became
the first Negro physician since Daniel
Hill Williams to be admitted as a fellow
of the American College of Surgeons four
years four years later he became a
deployment of the American Board of
surgery by examination rather than
through appointment appointment was a
courtesy due to him given his already
proven expertise in the field and the
courtesy extended to two Caucasian
junior harlem hospital staff members who
weren't hooking who are on medical
faculties dr. Reich couldn't join due to
his skin color in 1938 he was appointed
director of Harlem Hospital Department
of Surgery which at that time was a non
salary position held on a rotating basis
in 1943 he became permanent chairman of
the department at the hospital he also
initiated an uninterrupted flow of
research papers on trauma cases that
came through his busy emergency room and
later established a Cancer Research
Foundation on its premises by the early
1940s pharmaceutical companies supported
numerous investigations by his medical
team on the use of antibiotics
culminating in in the distinction that
his team was the first to use Oreo
myosin and human beings in 1938 Life
magazine called him the most eminent
Negro physician in the US Charles drew
who would soon earned similar
distinction was several years younger
than Wright and began his medical career
much later with such credentials noted
dr. W Monty u cob editor of the John of
the National Medical Association
Wright could have easily become a
wealthy man but he chose not to and
lived only on a modest salary the city
of New York paid him as a police surgeon
the most he was ever able to contribute
to a medical school was a
is $100 contribution he once made to the
one at Howard hmm at which at one point
is kur he was offered the deanship but
turned it down right died of a heart
attack in 1952 to the relatively young
age of 61 compared to fellow Georgia
native Joseph Griffin who died at 92
almost 30 years later just before he
died
Wright was preparing to attend the
inauguration of his brother-in-law
Harold d West who had just been named
the first Negro president of Meharry the
same Harold West who three years later
wrote back to Georgia governor Marvin
Griffin acknowledging the good deeds
done by Meharry alumnus Joseph H Griffin
Griffin hospital and clinic which was in
his third year of operation when Wright
died while write fulfilled the
scientific hopes of John Kennedy the
Negro physicians would prove that they
could hold their own against the best
medical minds
Joe griffin pursued economic and
political means of power available at
that time in the south to an ambitious
financially hungry Negro man of Medicine
and the passage goes on to explain that
while right donate only 100 dollars to
Howard University Medical School my
great-uncle donated what now amounts to
fifteen million dollars in stock to
Meharry Medical College Morris Brown
College here in Atlanta and Nelson
Chapel AME Church the dividends from
that stock go to those three school knew
that one church in those two schools oh
and I wanted to compare the two because
I felt both were very very brilliant men
but one decided he wanted to dedicate
himself to medical education while the
other side he wanted dedicated himself
to accumulating as much money as he
could and also he also just loved to be
the practice of surgery and I really
think of my great-uncle was alive today
if he had come up during the time that I
came but he probably going to Wall
Street or you probably would have been
coming industrialists if he could come
you know back in those days that he
couldn't have done that so I wanted just
to compare the two which is why I put
that passage in the book now the next
passage I want to read deals with my
great-uncle by the time he was a was an
elderly man and the fact that he had two
grants as he actually ended up having
three grandchildren and two grandsons
one of which he sent to Morehouse
College
Joseph Howard Griffin Perry now Joe went
to Morehouse in 1964 during the height
of the civil rights movement so he liked
a lot of young people in that day and
decided to leave college and join the
movement but instead of joining the
Student Nonviolent Coordinating
Committee or SCLC which were the two
most active groups here in Georgia
Alabama Mississippi you know in this in
this region Joe decided to join a group
called the free southern theatre the
free southern theatre were put on
theatrical presentations kind of
agitprop theatre demonstrations to poor
african-americans in Mississippi and
Louisiana Alabama to try to get them to
understand that they had to you know get
up off their Dustin and get their you
know take their seize their rights for
themselves they'll put on something like
say Waiting for Godot or something like
that anyway Joe and a group of other
members of the theatrical group got in
some trouble in Louisiana with some
racist they decided they didn't want
them there doing what they were doing so
they were apprehended one day on some
trumped-up charges by a local sheriff
and this was the same time that Chaney
Goodman and Schwerner but around the
same time that those three civil rights
workers in Mississippi were murdered so
Joe and his compatriots both one of whom
was a Frenchman they all thought they
were gonna die but they ended up be that
what ended up happening was they that
the chef's decide he was just gonna
scare him and they very shortly after he
scared them they left so Joe shortly
after that he decided to take these
civil rights workers to Bainbridge to
meet his grandfather and as a show is a
movie on TNT made clear maybe about
three or four months ago movie starring
Danny Glover a lot of people are under
the misimpression that when the civil
rights movement came down here everyone
african-american just said well my god I
would we were wondering where you're
gonna come down like come on let's go
yeah but that's that wasn't the case
most of african-americans behind closed
doors wanted segregation to end but they
were too frightened they were too
nervous about publicly demonstrating
that they wanted segregation to end so
when those civil rights workers came
often you had a lot of dissent you had a
lot of conflict within families where
the older people were saying well no
don't join those demonstrators because
you're gonna get in big trouble because
they remember what happened in the turn
of the century when african-americans
decided to fight for the rights and all
of the lynchings and mass
cruising everything so my great-uncle
was one of the people whose philosophy
was still look we want this thing to end
this Jim Crow thing to end sometime in
the future but right now don't join the
civil rights movement so Joe decided his
grandson decided to bring these civil
rights workers to brain vision this is
what happened not long after this this
trouble I had he was referring to the
trouble he had in his hand not long
after that Joe brought a group of his
active his friends to Bainbridge I took
them to granddad's howl office in the
hospital he recounted every as we sat in
the family room drinking cokes you have
to imagine what that was like here were
these dudes trying to blend in but
totally conspicuous complete strange to
the area I mean these guys would stop
traffic everywhere they went so here
they were a city in grad dad's waiting
room with everyone just staring at them
silently after a while granddad walked
in he came straight up to me and said
get these blankety-blank nuts out of my
hospital there's any changing to be done
in Bainbridge I'll be the one to do it
so that's the kind of like you know
gives you an idea of what his philosophy
wasn't just just his lower side
something that's also in its book one of
the top civil rights leaders here in
Atlanta Hosea Williams grew up in the
Carroll County Georgia and he went to my
great-uncle's a little boy as a matter
of fact my great-uncle was the first
person had him arrested Hosea Williams
was arrested during the civil rights
movements unlike something like 135
times but the first time he was ever
arrested was when he and another guy
went up to my great-uncle's first
hospital and they were dating these
women and who were watching patients at
night and they weren't supposed to be
going up to the hospital at night so my
great-uncle hid around the corner in a
with some police officers and had him
arrested for trespassing and so he said
if so he told me said like well you know
people were basically very respectful
dr. Griffin but they were also very
fearful of dr. Griffin and once during
the civil rights movement when he came
back to Bainbridge my great-uncle only
half jokingly said to him Hosea don't
come back to Bainbridge feel good
because we don't need your type of
activism so that's kind of like you know
his velocity is like you know hey we
need to go slow I'm the power here in
Bainbridge we don't need you guys coming
in here and there but then eventually
you know when when the gym when Jim
Crowe came down in 1964 and 65 then he
got on board and he became one of the
leaders who was behind the integration
of Bainbridge Schools so you know the
passages I just read
was just you know designed to give you
some notion of the the kind of is
ascension between the generations when
the civil rights movement came along
okay now the next passage I want to read
deals with the manner in which a man
like Joseph Griffin could he could you
know publicly he could can make some
sort of accommodation to the gym Co yet
to deal with but behind closed doors he
was every bit as proud and and desirous
of the eradication of Jim Crow in and
african-americans gaining their rights
and doing all they could as anybody else
was so these passages deal with how he
dealt with situations where he could
very well get in troubling I possibly
get killed and it also deals with the
grandfather of a man who's sitting in
the audience right here her belly who
who is also a very powerful man here in
the south
herb Dudley on number of businesses in
town of Dublin on the funeral home a 24
hour gas station a restaurant a casket
factory a number of different businesses
and he was like Joseph Griffin in that
they were wealthy men who were basically
like Godfather's of their community so
Joe Griffin and Herbert Dudley knew one
another so one day my uncle Joe was
telling herb Dudley about a situation he
encountered in the town of Blakely
Georgia and so I'm describing the
situation as him wearing a mask and how
he dealt with it so Uncle Joe wore a
mask
the same way he told herb Dudley in the
1930s that he once wore one as he drove
his big new tan Packard through the town
of Blakely on his way back to Bainbridge
from Stewart County a time before he
became as well known throughout the
region as he'd be by the 1940s and 50s
of Caucasians and Negroes alike and
perhaps he thought about the time he
lived and worked in Blakely as a brick
mason before going off to medical school
so he was proud to return through the
town now in a big shiny fancy Packard
and mary-louise his daughter was with
him and he liked to drive fast and she'd
like to encourage your father to drive
fast so he drove fast around the town
square and after they got past the town
square a police officer stopped a car
and when the officer walked up to the
driver's window he said boy what are you
doing speeding through this town of such
a fancy car I was just taking it back to
doctor dr. Griffin Bainbridge sir
replied Uncle Joe
leading the officer to the thing
Griffin was Caucasian well you just make
sure you get back to him in one piece
officer told him and don't go joyriding
with it you're here yes sir officer
Uncle Joe answered and the officer let
him move on after which she turned to
mary-louise and said we sure did fool
him then we darling
yes we did daddy she probably responded
but when the coast was clear and he
spoke to a small cleat he could trust
he'd register his palpable frustration
registers reality they didn't like
sometimes being forced to wear such a
mask like all the other Negroes wore
when they left the house each morning
he'd register his frustration by making
a joke out of the collective predicament
by using humor the most readily
available medicines who's frustrated
Negroes down through the years enabling
them to make light of the impossible
predicament that being a Negro added up
to Eunice irons Adams was telling me the
story watched as he did yet the day
after the voter registration meeting at
Macedonian Baptist Church he had been to
a voter registration me where you've
been trying to get African Americans in
the region register to vote pay their
poll taxes Richard to vote she watched
as he did it with a small clique of old
people who didn't work in southern
Caucasian homes he said I just don't
understand my people I declare if we
ever learned to work together and
cooperate we could get a hell of a lot
of things done now you take for instance
that group we were meeting with last
night all the mostly work in the white
folks homes and you have to understand
back in those days the whites who ran
the businesses in town twelve o'clock
every day they'd hang a sign in the
window saying gone to lunch so
everything closed because the whites
would went to eat this hot lunch that
these black women had fixed for them so
dr. Griffin said I told them not to go
telling those white folks that I told me
who to vote for but what we could do if
we were organized if we start together
is saying okay now tomorrow when
everybody comes home to eat lunch after
closing all the businesses at twelve
o'clock
we have poison in the food we'd poison
them off and that would limit a lot of
our problems but he said you know some
[ __ ] would go to work the next morning
and just walk around and keep yawning in
yawning till Miss Sally would say Susie
what's wrong with you
you've just been moping around in
yawning and Susie would say I was just
sleeping Miss Sally
then Miss Sally would say why are you so
sleepy Susie say well you see last night
dr. Griffin kept us up all night
depend on how he's going to poison y'all
when y'all eat lunch at 12 o'clock
so I just wanted to read that passage as
an example of the frustration that you
know very powerful men such as him felt
because of the predicament they were in
and the math they had to wear in a sense
the D no they were still very proud of
themselves and what they could do but
they also knew that the atmosphere was
such in the south it was extremely
difficult if not impossible to get
everyone else to join together to do
something about it because people
remember the terror and the oppression
that they had lived under and whether it
did it come down on them at the turn of
the century okay now the next passage I
want to read and I only have two more
passages to read this passage passage I
want to read deals with one of the ways
when she became wealthy because two ways
in which she became very wealthy was he
was one of the principal abortion
doctors in the in the southeast during a
time period when abortions really who
was a lot like the doctor in them in the
movie Cider House Rules he was like you
know women of all colors young women of
all colors from like Florida State
University the entire area would come to
him and get abortions the gospel get
abortions and that's one of the ways he
came in a lot of his money another way
he accumulated life his money was if a
patient's had property he would have
them deed property as collateral on
their medical bills and if they didn't
pay up he might foreclose they need my
giving like a three four years schedule
to pay their medical bills like you know
like you know they'd maybe they pay like
50 $60 a month on the bill and until he
paid it off and if they didn't pay up
he's foreclosing you know look you
meaningly a huge amount of property
through that method but anyway this
passage deals with it towards the end of
the book when I'm talking about
discipline practice and one of the
people who reviewed my book a guy for
emerged reviewed it for emerged magazine
misinterpreted this passage and that's
that's one of the reasons I I said
something about about reviewers that but
I said at the beginning of this reading
a lot of times what they'll do is
they'll take a snippet of a passage in a
book and totally misconstrue what the
snippets are what the what the passage
is trying to say because they give a
reader a totally distorted erroneous
sense of what the writer is doing so the
review of this reviewer for emerged
Megan it was basically a decent review
but the reviewer for emerged magazine
accused me of trying to rationalize my
great-uncle's this
becoming an abortionist and that wasn't
what I was doing at all what I was
trying to do was give the reader in this
chapter chapter 10 a sense of what a
woman a young woman 20 year old woman
say is feeling if she decides to make
the decision I'm gonna abort my child
what she's feeling when she decides
she's gonna go to the abortionist what
she's feeling after the abortion what
she's feeling
if the abortion is gets bashed up and
she knows she's gonna she's suffering
from septicemia and she's gonna die I
wanted to give the reader a sense of
what must be good what might be going
through her head of course you know I
can't possibly have this sense because
I'm not a woman and I'm you know I could
never get an abortion but I wanted to
try to get as close to the sense of what
could be going through her head as I
could so that's what I was doing in this
particular section of the book and I
also wanted to give the reader a sense
of what the abortion doctor must be
feeling and making the decision that I
want to perform abortion so this passage
this is an area of the book it's a
section of the book kind of a
stream-of-consciousness passage where
I'm talking about
Joseph Griffin and his decision to
become an abortion doctor and what might
have been going his mind that made him
sleep soundly at night knowing that he's
an abortion doctor and Joseph Griffin
had erred in a small-town Jim Crow deep
south with the daring that had caused
him to play plenty of sophisticated
games to get what he wanted
during that that caused him to collect
plenty of enemies and cause other types
of pain even as he alleviated medical
pain and no doubt he became hardened by
so many of the racial realities he was
forced to live with so what was one less
Caucasian child who would inevitably
inevitably be taught how to make life
difficult for Negroes even and even if
he too made life difficult
he may have reasoned that that was the
way you gained power either dominate or
be dominated and the only people he
could dominate during a life lived under
Jim Crow were fellow Negroes but with
Caucasians it was different this was a
different matter
Caucasians could dominate other
Caucasians too or maybe when he was
aborting a Caucasian pregnancy he
thought of the Caucasian mother maybe he
thought that at least she this young
desperate woman well learned to
appreciate this colored man who got her
out of her bind far more than she ever
thought she would appreciate someone of
black African descent or maybe or when
the embryo or fetus
he was aborting was a negro mother's
upon looking at the aborted
quote-unquote seedling he may have
thought you don't know how wonderful it
is that I have prevented you from
me into this world to fight poverty and
the ignorance of the family you would
have been born into which you may not
have even fought but it's simply accept
it simply embraced because you have no
nothing else or if it was an ambitious
Negro girl or co-ed he was performing
abortion for maybe he was only too glad
to ensure she could become something
more than the then another embarrassing
statistic ending up with a little dirty
naked pot-bellied Negro kid
among the many dirty and naked
pot-bellied Negro kids he had delivered
as cynically wise to grow out of infancy
okay now the last passage I wanna read
deals with the very end of the book a
passage it was quoted in a very
wonderful glowing review I received in
the front pages of Chicago Tribune at
the very end after I had to conducted
all my research and find out all these
things I went to my for the last time my
great uncle's great because he built
this very impressive mausoleum along us
I think it's US Highway 80 if I remember
correctly a highway there's the ghost do
the extreme south Georgia from from
Savannah all the way through I don't
know where it is but anyway it goes do
Savannah through Valdosta through
Thomasville on into Bainbridge and if
you if you come in from Savannah and
you're heading towards Bainbridge you
look it's like a four-lane highway you
look to your right you see that you
suddenly see the sloping heeling at the
top of you you see this like off-white
mausoleum where he's buried it caused
him $50,000 to built to building like
1958 but he's buried in that mausoleum
my great grandparents are buried in
there coupled my uncle since very it's a
very impressive mausoleum and the graves
around there surrounding it our graves
of family members and people who aren't
family members who can buy plots in this
particular Cemetery so anyway I was like
you know it's like it's a very end I was
on my way back to New York you know cuz
I drove every time I came down here to
do research I drove down here and I
would spend half of virtually every
month for it for about two years down
here in Georgia researching the book so
this is like basic what I was saying you
know to his spirit so to speak as I'm
standing it from the mausoleum
since you are deceased I wasn't supposed
to get close to asking hard questions
about your life since you are family I
was doubly prohibited from even thinking
about you in any way but the most
altruistic since you lived your life as
a colored Negro black afro-american male
and were South Georgia's first Negro
surgeon I was Tripoli Bahia prohibited
from even wondering if at any time you
weren't altruistic for me you were
supposed to be several layers above
being human and instead live in my mind
for the grandeur of my days and then
live in my children's mind for the main
for the rest of their days and their
children's minds for the rest of theirs
and so on as a legendary saint but now I
guess I've burst that bubble in the
process of exploring your life I've made
you human which for me which for all of
us I believe is the best thing for you
to be so thank you warts and all for
being who you were for accomplishing all
you accomplished against such tremendous
odds and in the process playing such a
large role in Who I am
thank you I want to thank you for coming
to the reading so now I want to open the
floor to get to any questions people
might have in the South Georgia area
where as you said you kind of burst the
bubble there of one of the myths of what
it was all about well I got a call I
sent a copy to mr. Paul cholesky who who
is in chapter 11 and was was a pastor
you know he's I quote Paul cholesky
verbatim cuz I thought it was very
fascinating interview a very candid
interview he's a among people who know a
lot about photography mini photography
they may knew Paul cholesky is he's a
fairly well-known documentary
photographer who has a net of yes some
of his photographs or exhibit is the
High Museum here in Atlanta he's very
interesting man excellent documentary
photographer and he and his family is
very prominent in Bainbridge so I sent
Paul copy of the book and Paul got back
to me like maybe a week later and told
me he thought it was really great I did
a great job and he basically I got the
sense that that he and a few other
people thought it was a very good book
and quite a few other people I would say
thought it was a very good book but as
far as other people getting back to me
and tell me what they think about it I
didn't I don't really know for sure I
did get it I did get a call from a
distant relative on my on the Griffin
side of my family who lives in Chicago
who lived in Bainbridge at the time my
great-uncle had his house
he called me when I was in Baton Rouge
Louisiana I got I got the message by
Remo because I was in Baton Rouge
working on a story for Rolling Stone
magazine this was like about I see it
like a month ago a little maybe a little
bit over a month ago and he told me that
he had read the book he's already didn't
a great job a very balanced job and he
called my cousin Mary Louise who I sent
a copy to you know autographed copy
telling him you know telling her
basically that I had a lot of respect
for her father after doing all this
research and he told me that Mary Louise
said well you know that may be true that
it's a great book but I still can't
bring myself to read it yet
you know because I'm too close to the
subject you know and it'll be too
painful for me to read the passages to
deal with you know the candid nature of
how my father you know became wealthy so
it's I think the jury's a little is
still out in South Georgia about the
book
although the Tallahassee newspaper did
reprint Jonathan Yardley's review I mean
they had a choice of many reviews to
reprint all of which were glowing except
for Jonathan Young's but the read the
review they decided to reprint with
Yardley's so I wrote him a letter
did they have all these errors and they
printed the letter where's Washington
Post did not print the letter any other
questions see I forgot what was the
atmosphere at that time concerning
abortion legally morally and oh it was
the atmosphere was of all areas in the
country where abortion doctors exists
the South particularly the rural South
is the area they had the toughest time
because you know this area of the
country is very very religious and you
have a lot of to the today you have a
lot of abortion doctors who are scared
to perform abortions because of what
happens you know I mean it's been a
couple of instances where abortion
dollars has been killed down here and in
in his time you know it was just
considered horrendous even though he you
know he didn't have the kind of problems
that something abortion doctors have now
because it was all very hush-hush
and it's Paul cholesky made it clear to
me you know people just thought you know
it's horrible the doctor Griffin is
performing these abortions but at the
same time they saw him is a wealthy
powerful man so they didn't you know
they said behind closed doors or you
know I was horrible but as Paul said
when he came to you know to do business
with him like when he came to do
business with Paul's father they said Oh
dr. Griffin you know come right on
he said he said they rolled out the red
carpet for him just like they would have
for the King of England so he had an
entree because of his wealth and power
that other African Americans did not
have I mean he could you like for
example he could go into say a
restaurant or store in Bainbridge then
African might not be able to go into
like he could go and order some food but
he wouldn't be wouldn't be able to sit
down there but other African Americans
in Bainbridge wouldn't even be able to
go in so that's kind of like you know
the entree that he had even though
people were where their attitude was
well you know dr. Griffin he performs
abortions and these same people if their
daughters got in trouble they were
called dr. Griffin and say you know
could you give our daughters an abortion
so it's that kind of hypocrisy which is
still common today where people would
you know they're the adages well you
know abortion is a horrible thing but if
I get in trouble you know there's a good
chance I'm gonna go seek out an abortion
doctor he the passages you read
concerning hypothetically what he was
thinking while he was performing the the
abortions were your own oh just my own
thoughts just my own sense of what he
might have been think were they any
writings or verbal hope is closed quotes
from other people that related to
actually what he felt and why he went
into that I couldn't find anybody who
could give me a notion or was willing
put his way he was willing to give me a
notion of what he might have felt it was
very difficult for me to get the
information about the portions because I
mean I did get eventually get court you
know because there were court records he
ended up having that you end up he's
being charged for abortion but he ended
up getting off my all day for it but but
the Eagles he ended up being charged in
1967 1967 and they had flouncy see a
what was the he was he was indicted for
five counseling portion they end up
being convicted on one but he was only
fine it was like he was slapped on the
wrist basically for the funeral or
excuse me in which court in bit in
Decatur County really ended up because a
young woman he performed an abortion on
from Florida State University ended up
getting sick and she almost died but she
came through but while she was in the
hospital
Tallahassee the the the district
attorney's office came and asked who
performing abortion she said Joseph the
dr. Joseph Griffin the Bainbridge so the
Georgia Bureau of Investigation places
hospital under surveillance for several
months ended up in dieting him for five
counts of abortion and the the lawyers
who came to defend him one of them was a
CB King very well-known civil rights
lawyer in from Albany CB King came a man
here in Atlanta Donald Halliwell who was
very close to my great uncle Halliwell
was was one of top civil rights lawyers
here in the state of Georgia as a matter
fact he was the lawyer who gave Vernon
Jordan his first job when George George
Rosco so Donna Halal my great uncle
we're like father and so they were so
close they were like father and son
so Halliwell came and some lawyers from
Savannah came and they all defended him
and he ended up being convicted on one
count of abortion but he was just fine
and given probation for a year and you
know he kept his license but by that
time he was like 80 years old so you
know he'd been doing it for several
years and I guess you know he just it
was beginning to lose his touch and then
shortly after that he he uh he just
wound down his practice and eventually
just retired right okay very interesting
potentially pivotal time of personally
it came at the latter stages oh yeah
yeah I mean he got off he was very lucky
as is Paul Paul cholesky was telling me
that and I said and I have in this uh
chapter were for Paul speaking Paul's
opinion was that if he had been indicted
like when he was like 50 or 50 or 60 or
something like that he would have
probably been able to get off it off
altogether because of the Wheeling's and
dealings that he did in the area but by
that time he's Paul stated he was old
and he couldn't wheel and deal the way
he could the way we way you could in
earlier years so you know but but he was
still very lucky because another
colleague of his a colleague who lived
in Tallahassee ended up losing
everything but this is because the woman
who who got sick died he was a car young
Caucasian woman from Jacksonville who we
ended up dying as a result of suffering
from septicemia and everything so he
ended up going to jail and losing
everything you know his practice all his
money at Sarah and
and so my you know my great-uncle got
off very very he was very lucky was able
to keep everything in and wine downs
practice the way he wanted to
so there were other doctors performing
abortions it wasn't being they work they
weren't being performed in the back of
the fireman died Oh their work they were
being performed in the back of the five
in diamond but it's my interview he's
told me like my father has a class made
the practices in all during dr. Carl
Gordon a vascular surgeon in Albany
there was always in a sizeable town or
city there was always at least one
physician who was performing abortions
you know it might have an
african-american position might have
been a Caucasian position but you can
find at least one who would perform
abortions along with the back-alley
people you're talking about you know you
know there was there was a wild question
you had the back-alley people you had
nurses I have an example of a nurse from
a town in southwest Georgia who
performed abortions as well she ended up
she ended up going to jail as well
because one of the women she was
performing abortions in torrent ended up
dying but just as your issue is you're
saying you had the back-alley people but
that but the physicians who decided to
perform abortions they were very much
sought after because among all who were
performing them the physicians were the
ones who really knew what they were
doing particularly the ob/gyn
so these were the ones that we're the
ones once once a physician once it was
made clear in the area you know you know
secretly you know the word spread that
this particular position performed
abortions quite often what would happen
was that doctor would lose all of his
legitimate practice and all only have an
abortion practice but my great-uncle was
able to get around that because his
hospital was the only Hospital for
african-americans in that area you know
and he was talking about segregation and
in at the beginning of his practices are
the first half of his practice there
were no hospitals african-americans
could go to later on they were
segregated wards for them to go to it
called Cajun hospitals but they weren't
gonna get treated at a segregate
Hospital the way they were gonna get
treated at Griffin Hospital so they
would continue to go to him so he he had
a general medical practice
he had a surgical practice and an
abortion practice all going at the same
time he was a big landowner and he owned
like buildings in which like business
african-american businesses in
in in Bainbridge warehousing businesses
that in buildings that he owned he also
owned the lien on all the taxis in
Bainbridge all the african-american
taxis in Bainbridge so he so he was you
know very busy man and a man who
accumulated a lot of wealth and practice
medicine as well as as you know practice
dis entrepreneurship brought up another
interesting point in all of these liens
and Holdings were they all predominantly
in the black community or they were also
really he had no holdings in the white
well he did have he'd had some holdings
in like him as a matter of fact um he
owned some buildings this strange I
remember I was talking to his grandson
Joe about this and Joe somehow when he
was growing up he remembered that there
were there were serious houses across
the street from them that he could only
run into Caucasians
the law in Bainbridge said you cannot
rent this after murders so he owned
these houses and rented out to Caucasian
tenants so and there are also areas of
damage I remember when Bainbridge Junior
College I was told when Bay would you
junior college decided to accumulate the
land for their for their campus they had
to buy from him among other people so he
did have some real estate holdings that
you know in which he dealt with
Caucasians to the extent of how how much
what percentage of his holdings were
bought from Caucasians Oh ever I can't
tell you but I do know that it it
predominantly has holies work within
that fear I've met a new apartheid
doctor exactly a successfully that's the
deal right being like basically
Godfather's in their community how did
they fare like after the civil rights
movement was successful because it was
an insular you know african-american
communities that they were successful in
if they were Godfather like type people
how did they fare once the community was
leave open up well they feared they
fared pretty well because you have to
remember that by the time the community
was opened up I mean you know by the
time I great-uncle closed his practice
he was very wealthy as a millionaire he
didn't have to you needed that he didn't
have to do anything for the rest of his
life and they still they still had a
this measure of respect in the community
wasn't like after Jim Koch Jim Crow came
down you had a situation like you know
the collapse let's hunt down the
collaborators because basically all the
African Americans were collaborators in
the situation because they felt that
they had to be collaborators they wanted
to survive so I think that that the the
history that the media gives us this
impression that you know after
everything came down well first of all
to get the impression that you know
everyone was like you know publicly
supporting the movements when it wasn't
the case usually it was the young people
that were supportive publicly supporting
the movement I mean you had some cases
where the the towns just basically got
up and said look we're not gonna take
this anymore like in Birmingham or
Albany Georgia where you had like no
certain campaigns but when all this this
the Jim Crow was eradicated it wasn't
like you know people said well dr.
Griffin you know you weren't on the
front lines while we were because most
of most of the people period weren't on
the front lines it was just the lp were
on the front lines so they you know they
they were all happy including my
great-uncle happy for you to come now
they were just fighting that it was not
gonna come down to people gonna get
massacred so then you know once it came
down he said well you know he said well
I'm glad they came down but you know
there's other work to do
there's American I have a speech in here
where he talks to Fort Valley State
College when he and he talks about how
you know we had got we have got to
become landowners we have got to
participate in running the economy down
here because you know there's a lot of
opportunity down here and if we don't
become the owners we're gonna miss out
on the opportunity so so that's that's
basically the way he was he was he was
still quite esteemed it's just that like
most African Americans down he was not
one of the people in the front lines
forcing the change
any other questions
just briefly about his concern and just
about the movement I would think someone
of that wealth and what have significant
influence influence broad political
influence because of the type of medical
services he was providing for the total
community law as well as as well could
you speak a bit on his political
influence if I mean since you would say
even during the days of segregation he
would have been able to be a power
broker in like say Southwest Georgia
like almost like a participated in the
smoke-filled rooms where they did their
negotiating and debating who's gonna run
for office are you saying that sense of
what yeah we're just I would think that
he had a lot of secrets over you know
within both black and white community
and from that comes some level of
political stature as well and being able
to influence people in different ways
well I think that his political stature
in the influence in the secret city kept
we're probably the reason why he got off
so lightly when he was charged with
abortion because they like he had so
many people secrecy he probably like you
know a lot of powerful people or you
know my 15 year old daughter when she
got pregnant dr. Griffin kind of thought
got us out of our hot water got us out
of trouble so I he willed it he willed
it influence in that regard but you
didn't have african-americans down here
no matter how powerful they were you
didn't have them participating like in
the smoke-filled room to discussions
with political bosses of the Democratic
parties because back in those days it
was all segregated I mean
african-americans could vote if they
could pay their poll taxes and depending
on on where they were I mean there were
certain counties down here where
virtually no african-americans voted
because they didn't usually they were
predominantly african-american counties
and they didn't want F America's vote
because if they did they would be taken
over by African Americans so you had
certain counties where were much worse
than other counties and apparently
Decatur County was not as bad as say
there's a county outs I think it's Burt
County outside of Augusta where it was
really really bad and said but Decatur
County
most African mericans did not vote but
if you could pay your poll tax it was
just it was a it's a significant amount
of money you could vote but you couldn't
vote and did
the Democratic primary because
Democratic primary until 1946 was all
Caucasian so you had a situation down
here where african-americans could vote
in the general election but who was
there to vote for because the Democratic
primary was tantamount to the general
election and it was all Caucasian so so
you know he couldn't even no matter how
wealthy and influential he was because
by law the Democratic Party was
segregated he couldn't participate you
know he could go in and vote in the
November election but you know he could
vote for somebody who was certainly
wasn't gonna win because they were the
only power down it was a democratic
party
any more questions okay I would like to
thank you and if anyone would like to to
buy any of the books I'm available for
signing and and that will do it thanks
very much